soit rosenberg merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rtl
concernant tout d'abord ce revirement de
la part de joe biden pourquoi le
président américain selon vous at il
décidé de faire un cadeau à un gala
merkel alors qu'elle est en fin de
mandat et surtout à vladimir poutine
qu'ils traitaient il ya encore quelques
semaines de deux tueurs
bah écoutez c'était prévu déjà depuis
des semaines et des semaines
je crois que l'administration byden et
réaliste elle brandit pas des menaces
qu'elle ne pourra pas mettre en oeuvre
le le gazoduc collodi est terminée il
reste plus qu'un mois et demi de
construction il ya moins de 100 km 94
même 50 et donc c'est une cause perdue
il a très bien dit qu'ils auraient envie
mais à la fois les rapports avec les
russes les allemands et donc c'était un
enjeu qui n'était pas vraiment important
maintenant pour washington qui veut
maintenant on en reparlera peut-être
tout à l'heure bien sûr replacer les
relations avec la russie dans un cadre
beaucoup plus globale et donc d'assurer
une stabilité stratégique et surtout une
président humilité et donc là dessus
c'est quand même un geste de bonne
volonté et en bonne diplomatie
évidemment les américains attendront un
geste de réciprocité de la part de
vanières poutine
c'est justement cet équilibre très
délicat que les observateurs les moins
bien intentionnés vont observer et que
les critiques vont si cette église n'est
pas maintenu si on a l'impression que
c'est l'une des parties qui a emporté un
peu plus à ce moment là joe by dell sera
un peu critiqué voilà un petit peu alors
évidemment on dit qui aura pas de
communiqué indique un savait difficile
tout ça c'est des manoeuvres pré-sommet
ses classiques
je rappelle aux à nos chers auditeurs
qu' il n'y a pas eu vraiment de sommets
depuis 2009 c'est exactement lorsque
carter avait rencontré drège des 179
ensuite reagan a rencontré caen bat chef
en 85 qui s'est passé énormément d'année
là c'est quand même le premier sommet et
qui est dans une qui se devait se tenir
dans une atmosphère difficile certes
tendu on le verra mais au moins il ya un
geste de bonne volonté des deux côtés et
c'est ce que ce ce cet aspect là qu'il
faut bête l'accent mon sens juste avant
le décollage à bord de l'avion forcé air
force one le président américain tout de
même assuré que le but de son voyage
était de faire savoir clairement je suis
ta putin et à la chine que les états
unis et l'europe étaient soudés on se
dit ça n'est quand même pas en confiance
tout ça pour apaiser des rapports comme
vous nous le décrivions il ya quelques
instants nombre
c'est normal il va pas dire que l'europe
et les états unis puisqu'il vient il
vient on va pas reparler tous les
sommets qui fait il veut il veut
rassembler le monde démocratique
effectivement le fameux des dix quoi de
faire un sommet des démocraties et donc
mon la chine on n'en parle pas parce que
c'est vraiment c'est là le point délicat
le point justement il faut il faut
mettre de côté
l'affrontement entre les etats-unis et
la chine qui est à la faute membre
technologique stratégie commerciale
civilisationnel de rapports plus
difficiles avec la russie que je que
lui-même byden ne qualifie pas
d'affrontement puisque le vrai affronte
nice avec la chine certains américains
nourrissent j'aurais pas l'illusion
l'espérance qu'un jour on va des tâches
et la russie de la chine charges taxes
et c'est pas envisagée avant vos pré
longtemps concrètement c'est normal
puisque poutine est un interlocuteur
très difficile coriace qui a montré son
habileté byden montre t il
il montre très bien qui n'est pas un
naïf et qui vient également pour
négocier et trouver un accord trouvé un
accord pour idir a pas un accord
peut-être actes et surtout les plombs
puisque
c'est trop tôt pour discuter de manière
technique sur le sur le nucléaire sur le
terrorisme souvenez vous la dernière
fois on avait discuté que lavrov avait
proposé une réunion des chefs d'état
major
on verra ce qui sortira du 16 mai au
moins il y aura une rencontre des deux
chefs d'état qui se connaissent déjà
ils vont déblayer un saut d'obstacles et
on verra si effectivement il y aura une
différence de perception et surtout une
volonté d'approfondir ce que j'appelle
une première petite percée je l'espère
une petite percée c'est pas évidemment
c'est pas d'un seul coup on va pas
régler le contentieux qui existe déjà
depuis une dizaine d'années bien avant
l'ukraine les rapports sont derrière à
propos de la série des des détresses des
12 mai au moins j'assiste là dessus il
ya une volonté des deux chefs d'états
d'établir et surtout de passer en revue
une série de questions telles que le
terrorisme le désarmement le changement
climatique l'écologie réparer de
l'article byden par là évidemment des
droits de l'homme du can have any donc
ils poutine voudra parler également de
l'assaut sur le congrès le 6 en disant
oui
volot critiquer mais vous aussi vous
n'êtes pas irréprochable donc essayons
de rétablir la balance telle qu'elle est
voilà un petit peu l'optique de ce
sommet et je crois que c'est par rapport
à ces critères qu'il faudra juger s'il a
été positif succès toujours
c'est par une de boxe nalement c'est pas
quelqu'un qui tient scène des coups à
l'autre souvent la presse dit voilà
c'est ring de boxe
non le succès sera le qui aura une
progression c'est à dire que le sommet
aura été une valeur ajoutée dans la
compréhension qu'ont les deux présidents
de la situation actuelle et une un
éclaircissement des points sur lesquels
on peut progresser avec de la bonne
volonté
si les circonstances le permettent et si
chacun y met de la bonne volonté alors
souvent dans ce genre de situation
évidemment les
hors personnel joue un pèse la porte
parole de la maison blanche a rappelé
avant ce départ un que joe biden
connaissait certains de ses dirigeants
dont le président poutine depuis des
décennies at elle dit quelle est la
relation entre ces deux hommes vous vous
la voyez comment pour l'instant vous
savez c'est eux
on a beaucoup de photos en tête ou deux
le vice-président en 2011 je n'avais
encore en gt en russie à l'époque
finalement ils ont jamais eu d'atomes
crochus
il n'y a pas une vraie sympathie entre
les deux hommes comme il y en a pas eu
entre obama et poutine under poutine a
des bonnes relations
par exemple il avait avec avec beaucoup
d'autres dirigeants et pas uniquement de
son équipe de son groupe de son décès ne
sont de sa catégorie mais avec baden
pour l'instant ce ça a été purement
factuel c'est ce n'a pas été vraiment
chaleureux alors est-ce que la glace va
briser
je pense pas dès la première n'est pas
la première puisque byden justement veut
se démarquer de 33 me disais moi je les
bons rapports je respecte poutine
mais en même temps je suis dur il joue
un peu double jeu quoi jouer les
matamores en disant je me fais pas
rouler alors qui c'est un petit peu
comme il a critiqué ses propres services
de sécurité byden qui est un vrai
professionnel ne fera pas donc
effectivement pour l'instant les
relations s'en est froide sont distantes
sont des relations de travail et pour
bâtir ses relations vous avez tout à
fait raison
il faudra d'autres sommets alors est ce
que là la pratique annuelle des sommets
que j'ai connus lorsque je commençais ma
carrière étudiants où tous les ans et se
voyaient ils se voyaient en 72 73 74
sera ce serait effectivement intéressant
puisque ça montrerait que il ya un début
de redémarrage
il n'ya pas évidemment de détendre c'est
beaucoup trop tôt d'en parler mais il ya
une volonté comme je dirais déblayer ces
problèmes de les examiner ensuite
demandé aux ministres techniques
se pencher et d'arrivée des modus
vivendi ou des semblant d'accord donc ça
serait bien mais qu'effectivement les
deux hommes établissent des relations
travailler justement le sait jouer c'est
l'occasion de tester cette possibilité
de continuer à travailler ensemble et se
réunir en tête à tête pratiquement une
fois par an merci aux jeunes d'ambert
gars d'avoir été avec nous nous avons
apporté notre analyse en direct sur rt
france